it and this person thinks that she's
allowed on my team no you're not really
okay on this tangent I'm getting a lot
of hatred on this yeah I don't like fat
models here we go this is what I'll tell
you because I believe that those women
who are models they're genetically
gifted okay God gives everybody or
whoever Yahweh Krishna gives you gifts
that's their gift to be tall and hot and
freakishly skinny and that's the [ __ ]
thing and clothes look great on them for
whatever reason is it a cultural norm
yes so that's great so let that hot
chick be hot don't take that away from
her and give it to [ __ ] fat bride it
doesn't look as good let's be honest and
it's not healthy to be overweight it's
not a good thing can ask why are we
[ __ ] separating every [ __ ]
Crawford is stunning yeah you know who
Kate Moss's
of course right maybe one plus-size
model special being a model is special
yeah stay skinny and they have to stay
hot yeah it's not fair you get to eat
you know chili dogs and be a supermodel
no you know what they're kind of
psychologically broken too you know I
have a friend well she's in the our
friend she's in the porn industry she
was like do you know how fit I have to
stay that's a big tracker in my life
she's like I have to go to this [ __ ]
strip club I can't eat this giant bowl
of chili whenever the [ __ ] I want to
like it's something that's constantly in
her mind and that is the price they have
to pay a gift and they work hard and
it's not easy I've never modeled but I
watch America's next top 24 burgers no
Bobby's favorite my favorite 29 book is
a half asian half Swedish male model
okay I want suck his dick really I would
make may I see him yeah oh dear God
that's a good one
Wow let me see he looks like a painting
he's kind of like
young Keanu Reeves yeah now let me see
something better okay if you were going
to if listen if you were gonna sell
menswear right you're a company right
that's that's what you have that's right
right would you have this guy right
right or me
right right but you know you would if I
if it was up between him and I and I got
the call you got it yeah I'll just be
like what the [ __ ]
right now conversely if they want to
cast the next sitcom and they need the
funniest [ __ ] guy in the room are
they gonna call this guy they do they
always do this the high guy
they always do hire you because that's
your gift I know some situations where
like for instance I don't want to say
any names but we have a guy that was on
the show who auditioned for a sitcom
pilot this guy is one of the funniest
dudes
mekka Mexican dudes I've ever seen he's
young oh yeah
the audition for the show and then he I
go you got a ride and he goes no dude
they gave it to the good-looking guy
when I know I don't care what this
good-looking guy looks like there's no
way he's as talented as well notion
let's put that good-looking guy in
[ __ ] Peoria Illinois across from the
racecar track next to the black girls
strip club yeah for a week and let's see
if he can do you know six shows and make
people ride or go to Lake Tahoe with
Howie knave or whatever his name is
right and do 14 shows
yeah there's no way that's what's that
but that's what not Hollywood doesn't do
that Hollywood right just drives me
crazy
that's right yeah just nobody would be
real damn being real there is a
disconnect yeah
between just look man look what I see
let me just say something go ahead I
want to see that you and Tom or whoever
has a Netflix special you're like and I
go wow no I go oh it went when I heard
Joey Diaz got one yeah yes half-hours
generous go ahead on Netflix right now
yeah but there's some times when you go
yeah yeah right it's like some guy
that's there's no connect just there's a
desire you're getting me all fired up
yeah get things and it's like whoever
the network is whoever they approve and
then you and then you see guys that are
you legitimately deserve it right they
have the look they have the ethnicity or
whatever they might have but they have
it and they never get anything it just
drives me [ __ ] crazy but as you know
cuz you've been in this business long
enough after a while that [ __ ]
disappears correct that the blips the
people that get stuff that's kind of
unmarry very infrequently does it happen
where somebody can kind of rise to that
and stay there so the cream always rises
and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] will go
away you think so all the time a hundred
percent yeah it's happened time and time
again and that's why somebody like you
can work as long as you have but the
cream though sometimes isn't right
not true who do you know that well we
won't say I'm gonna name it name because
it's a positive thing go ahead right
I believe that Ricky groom deserves
something oh yeah yeah yeah and
definitely because I watched him every
night and I got I said to myself yeah
he's a plain looking white dude who was
kind of like slouchy right
he has no backbone really he's just no
shoulders he's just like he walks around
my bones are brittle or whatever right
yeah and he's always like how are you
pretty good but my daughter or what you
know me just it's always kind of like a
little negative and he was used to be
just a riff guy ride he used to be a guy
that just you know what do you do for
living and then he would do a bit right
but now he's working hard to just have
an act he's a really funny guy and he
may or may not get anything but and
there's a probably 50 guys I can name
that are like that that I go there
because of the time that we live in now
where it's like just a plain old white
guy right yeah it's gonna be harder yeah
are you going from the white guys right
now you know what I am no I know out of
very talented people that that are being
kind of on the outskirts because they
are unfortunately white guys right now
yeah it's not like it's it's like if
racism reversed and black people were
lynching white people right I wouldn't
be like you know me yeah finally
I mean it'd be like it's a sad thing of
course I want everyone to work right I I
think that you know throughout
showbusiness ethnics like myself yeah
yeah we you know we I mean in the late
in the late 90s a be set up a meeting
with ICM with me and they looked at me
from across the table and said we think
you're funny
I know and they go we can't sign you
because you will never work
Gee's and I go what it's like it's just
your type it's like you've never
work and now look I know my point though
is there but that you know so you know I
don't like it either way yeah but here's
the thing and here's the truth about our
business okay I'll have people say to me
isn't it great that female comedians are
now equal and everything go listen this
is not the truth if you look at who's
actually generating tickets and who's
really working there's like five female
acts really yeah the numbers are always
the same but the per if there's one big
female comic they go well there's Amy
Schumer yeah and you're like [ __ ]
that's one yeah now don't worry about it
I know you're worried cuz you're like
the white guys are losing control yeah
I'm very worried don't worry the way
here's it here's a truth I think it's
kind of a fad like everything else in
our business and the pendulum is gonna
come back and all the white guys will
have their [ __ ] again that's my
prediction you really think that yeah I
do happy you look I don't like you
nodding like that like the way you're
nodding hey man I I don't think so I
think it's welcome it's gonna level out
[Music]